now ukraine has is it true ukraine has
always been
this rope that's in the middle of a tug
of war between the us and russia
right the ukraine's always been kind of
in the middle between this
constant tug-of-way no no i don't think
so i mean the the uh
no there's a there there are differences
within ukraine itself but
in fact
listen
in 1997 russia and ukraine signed a
treaty a treaty of friendship
in
uh
2010
there was an agreement
well first of all there was an agreement
between russia and ukraine
which allah
about dividing the black sea fleet just
the molotov
no no no no no that's some that's
something different
there's
one of the one of the soviet navy
was divided into fleets there was a
pacific fleet the northern fleet the
black sea fleet
well you know with the breakup of the
soviet union
the black sea fleet which docked at
sevastopol which is in crimea
had you know had to be divided between
ukraine and crimea was ukrainian
territory
and and russia and an agreement was
reached on that
uh you know how the ships and and the
facilities were to be divided
and russia
agreed to lease the port of sevastopol
on ukrainian territory and to base
troops there with ukraine's agreement
and that that agreement was renewed in
2010 okay
uh and in 2017 it was again renewed up
until
2042
and in 2017
the agreement was
if i recall correctly
that in return for the use of the port
facilities
uh russia would give ukraine a discount
on gas
which supplied ukraine of course all
these agreements became dead letters
when russia just decided to seize crimea
right yeah because they was after maidan
right
that was right that was almost like two
months after that yeah well it was after
yeah it was after after maidan right it
was after my dad but so so the the
president
um what was the name of the president
porsche uh poroshenko during the maidan
uh
but he was not president at that
who was that at the time it was at the
time of of the maidan
victory yanukovych
still the president and he was uh more
of the russian-backed president the the
let's go back real quick the orange
revolution yeah well that was 2004. that
was 2004. yeah and what was the what was
the reason for the orange revolution
again
the the election of
falsification of the election results
between between yeah
and victor yushenko yushenko okay and
yushenko was the guy who was backed by
the us and yanukovych was the guy who
was backed by russia well it's hard to
say i mean i think that uh
i think he had a didn't didn't uh i
forget his name again the other guy the
guy who was i just said was backed by
the u.s
and victor yushenko yushenko his wife
worked in
i know his wife i mean his wife is from
chicago just as i am wow i mean she said
for the ukrainian community in in
chicago i i knew her actually before she
married him and didn't didn't she work
in politics in the u.s a little bit she
were well she worked um
she worked in she had a job in the state
department but i that was not uh
i wouldn't attach too much importance to
that the real conflict in
uh 2004
was over the integrity of the election
result because
who was the guy's name that won well
yushenko won b first of all the the the
he won because protests forced the new
election right he didn't officially win
though
originally
yanukovych one right
but
there were signs of massive
voter fraud
that led to the protests
that were known as the orange revolution
the the candidate who lost was viktor
yushenko
and the the crisis was defused
finally
with agreement to have an a new election
under tight control
which took place and reversed the the
result
of the first election
instead of yanukovych winning it was
yushenko who won right the position of
the u.s at that time was that we are in
favor of of of honest elections
not so much well isn't it also
convenient for the us and if you look at
the history of the cia that there was a
massive revolution there uh on the
claims of election fraud that the
russian-backed president the
russian-backed president actually won
and now there's fraud and now we're
going to have this orange revolution and
the u.s backed president is going to be
put in
uh i you know i wouldn't uh
i wouldn't overestimate this is what we
always do in the u.s
we overestimate our own importance uh in
the situation uh the thing is that uh
yushenko was backed by the western
ukrainians
uh
and
a yanukovych by the eastern ukrainians
uh and
the
the i mean in effect yanukovych accepted
the result
and he then
with the help of u.s advisers by the way
including
paul manafort
uh
prepared to run again and this time he
did win
he was elected
so because a largely out of
disappointment with yushenko on the part
of ukrainians
and his on
you know certain unfulfilled promises
which maybe
you know given the nature of ukrainian
politics maybe he would have had he he
was well intentioned
but maybe he had a a uh
he also got poisoned right yushenko well
that came yeah that that that that uh
that as well
but
after the
after the first round
when they prepared for the second round
uh you know the you know the the
uh
he was poisoned
he was poisoned and his face was was
disfigured
and uh
but he won but he won the the election
and and uh
yanukovych accepted that result
and he was advised
including by the u.s by u.s people like
paul manafort just to prepare for the
next election which he did
and he won that one right
how now how is that first election
how did they redo that did they redo the
votes
no they just uh they just uh announced
new a new election they would just they
said yeah do it all over again yeah
okay yeah and to see i mean and uh it
would have been pos you know had there
not been all this vote fraud
those the new election might have come
up with a result very much like the
first one but the difference but you
know this the second election was held
under under tighter control
and uh it it showed that
that the winner was yushenko
which is what people were saying all
along that that he had won the first
time too
right and and uh that result suggests to
me that that was right
that that it was machinations and voter
vote fraud that made it possible for
yanukovych to win the first time now
when he came back in 2008
he won right and then
well if there was
both sides i mean there there may have
been to some extent who knows
but both sides accepted the result